our good friend fresh back from mobile
alabama at the senior bowl the man who
pens the mmqb for sports illustrated so
expertly every week albert brewer back
here on the rich eisen show how you
doing albert i'm good how are you doing
i am great so what was the thing that
everyone was talking about down there as
you know it's i mean
uh honestly if i had a if i had to put a
list of
nfl events
the most gossip ridden nfl events
i would go well i'd go combine one right
right it would be it would be senior
bowl week two and then super bowl week
three i think if i had a if i had to do
a power ranking of most gossip laden nfl
weeks
number two would be senior bowl in my
estimation would you agree on that front
yeah yeah i would say so i mean it's
good too because they're i mean as you
know and i know you've been in these
situations there's a it's a little bit
of a smaller circle i would say at the
senior bowl versus the combine right and
that you know that actually lends itself
to more gossip um for obvious reasons so
it's always a good week and i'd say a
couple things i mean first of all you
know the brian flores lawsuit
dropping is we were all out of price i
think was wednesday
um you know obviously like by the time i
mean
i i'd say within the half hour of that
of that dropping it was basically what
everyone was talking about and so many
people there obviously have connections
to to
to brian flores and and know him um and
then you know i i a lot of coaches um
you know coaches a lot of young scouts
um are affected by this and affected by
this topic and have been affected by
this topic so that's one
you know then i think number two um is
the quarterback situation going into the
off season and how uncertain everything
is and how average the group of the
senior bowl look and this is a senior
bowl where i mean pretty much every one
of the top guys except matt corral was
out there practicing
and i'm telling you rich there was a
little bit of a
i don't know you know like like i don't
know if there's a single starter out
here there's a single nfl starter out
wow
that you know i think that that sort of
adds to
the uncertainty of is russell wilson
going to be available
is aaron rodgers going to be available
what's going to happen with desean
watson and so
um you know like last year it felt like
there was um last year felt like there
was going to be this you know land rush
for quarterbacks i don't think it quite
played out that way you know and this
year because the draft class is
um not great at the position i would say
probably
like the worst since 2013 um at the very
least
um you know i think that there's going
to be more suitors out there
looking for veteran quarterbacks
which could jack the market up for those
who are available um
okay so let's let's take that part first
then
um what is the general sense of rogers
being available you know you
you hear that uh he's had great
communication lines open with green bay
that did not exist certainly by this
point last year and
not all the way up until training camp i
guess
uh and then you also hear he's buying
land in tennessee
you know um so
which would be a fascinating spot we we
on this show talked about it earlier
this week thinking that titans would be
a terrific spot if again
they want to move on from tannehill and
and eat salary and what have you that
might mean what what do you think of
rogers and what was the general sense of
that over this past week right i don't
think anybody knows exactly what to
expect with him he's unpredictable um
and i think there are two sides to it um
you know the first side is like i think
the personal side which
his relationship is in a better place
with a lot of people in that building
primarily the general manager brian good
counsel and that makes a big difference
that's a big deal
um i also think you know like that if
you listen to the way i'm talk wait wait
he talked and rich i know you know you
pay attention to this stuff
if you listen closely like to his words
after he broke bret farb's record listen
to the appreciation for playing in green
bay the appreciation for being part of a
historic franchise the appreciation for
getting to play his own games at lambeau
he wasn't talking that way a year ago
and so like i i think like on the
personal side of it his relationship
with people in the organization
and his relationship with you know i
think the the the fan base and the stan
and and and that place in general
is in a much better place than it was a
year ago and that's a plus
the second part is the professional part
of it and
the packers really did go all in this
year and did operate in a different way
and for as much talk as there was about
the packers being conservative they
weren't this year they mortgaged
contracts they they took swings on guys
like randall cobb and whitney merciless
and jaylen smith over the course of the
year
and that's put them in a spot now where
their cap is an issue aaron rodgers is
going into a contract year so if you're
the team you don't want to let them go
into a contract year and then risk
losing them for nothing on the other end
you'd like to get them to sign an
extension
if you're going to go into the season
with him as your quarterback um you know
and then there are some aging pieces on
the roster and so
that part of it like were they we they
they were in such a good spot going into
last year this year there are some
challenges that didn't exist and so
that's what's going to be fascinating
about this is how
do you
reconcile all of it the personal is in a
better place than it was last year the
professional
might not be in quite as good a place
um i think it's unpredictable right now
um you know i know they've met and
they've talked and that obviously i
think it the communication is way better
than it was a year ago
um but obviously i think a big domino
that everybody's waiting on and if he
does become available then i think you
know we're going to be hearing about
some of the same teams we did a year ago
and obviously i think at the top of the
list would be the denver broncos but a
team like the titans that didn't have
their hat in the ring last year um you
know i think a team like that that there
are teams like that that i think are
going to kind of come out of the
woodwork as well
now what about russ because um i guess
by this point in time albert breer
there's going to be no change in seattle
right i mean it's carol's under contract
for a very long time and john schneider
i mean they haven't made any moves so i
know that the whole conversation is
nobody knows what's in the mind of jody
allen but i guess we do know
stay the course and the question is is
russ cool with that like what's going on
there yeah and you know he wasn't happy
loud the thing is like he wasn't happy
last year and that was coming out of a
12 and four year and they won the
division right and i mean like this like
looks like a team like you know i said
the packers need some retooling because
of the cap but the packers are still
that's still a he uh like a very very
talented roster with a lot of really
good players on it
i don't know rich can you say the same
thing about seattle right now right
i mean that's the thing is so
if last year was a page turner for for
russell wilson as far as this is going
to be the second half i'm kicking off
the second half of my career and i want
to put myself in position to wear a gold
jacket
and you know i i want to be all pro and
i i i i want to be on the super bowl
stage like can he trust that the team's
going to be able to get them there fast
enough and is it
best for the seahawks to go forward with
russell wilson either i mean i
like look they've got two first round
picks they they need to rebuild the
roster to some degree um but they don't
have any first trumpets i'm sorry i did
the opposite of that but they don't have
a first round pick they need to rebuild
the roster they've got one piece in the
roster that could bring back a lot
um you know i think jody allen's you
know roland is interesting just because
i do know there's a feeling there that
she wants russell um to stick around
but
i mean if you look at it like what's
best for russell what's best for the
seahawks
i sort of do think this thing has
reached its natural conclusion
so
you know we'll see what happens but it
does at least feel to me like maybe the
best thing for everybody is this is the
time when you pursue a divorce we'll see
what happens albert prayer the mmqb
sports illustrated at albert brewer on
twitter right here on the rich eisen
show let's now revisit the brian flores
lawsuit and again i'm i'm sure
there's a whole host of stuff that
passed your ear gate that's conjecture
and rumor and you know you're
you know uh what you can feel
comfortable reporting out what was the
general sense
of the hundred thousand dollars
for each loss tanking accusation of
brian flores is to
to stephen ross that you were hearing
about and what what what comes out of
mobile from your general sense of that
part of this lawsuit yeah i mean i i
it's hard because like it's um you know
obviously like brian floors what he's
pursuing here has changed um in another
area you know and and obviously the
diversity of coaching ranks and
the diversity of the executive ranks and
in the in the nfl
but
i mean that is a heavy heavy accusation
and
you know in particular rich at a time
when the nfl is you know pursuing like
deals with every gambling outfit you
know under the under the sun whether
it's draftkings fanduel those sorts of
places caesar's you know caesar's name
is on a stadium now which i think would
have blown all of our minds ten years
ago right um it's just i mean and then
like they're gonna have in stadium
betting you know i think you know
relatively soon where you're gonna be
able to like prop that on on individual
plays
um you know the fact that the nfl has
sort of gone all in on this now
uh you know and now you have a case like
this come up i mean i think this is this
is like shoeless joe you know what i
mean if this is true
and so you know i think the nfl knows
that this accusation
needs to be like needs to be
investigated and investigated very very
thoroughly and the hard thing is going
to be
is there if there isn't a paper trail
then how do you prove it like how do you
prove if stephen ross said that and i
don't think brian flores would lie but
if stephen rob said that to somebody how
do you prove he wasn't joking about it
because tanking was a subject of
discussion
like the entire off that that entire
year in miami and you can remember they
were building drafts building up draft
picks building up um cap space building
building a a treasure chest of of assets
and trading away guys like laramie
tunzel and michael fitzpatrick and
robert quinn and ryan tanil and so you
know i
i think that the the the the
the interesting thing here is going to
be whether or not the nfl could find any
sort of smoking gun
um that shows that this was a real thing
and this wasn't something that was just
part of banter inside the building
because what everybody on the outside
was talking about that whole year was
how the team was tanking for a
quarterback and if there's any truth to
it
i don't know how stephen ross can go
forward as an owner you know and i know
owners don't like to be in the business
of taking each other's team teams away
because they don't want to set
precedence and all the rest of it
um but you know i don't know how
you have you know
an owner
you you you allow an owner to go forward
if he is literally fixing the outcomes
of games
and doing it at a time
when
the integrity of the game needs to be
tied up at the highest level because
you're pursuing all these deals with all
these different gambling outfits and
then what are you hearing about um
others joining brian flores i mean it's
a class action lawsuit right now other
than hugh jackson raising his hand and
grambling and saying well there were a
bunch of plans that jimmy haslam and the
cleveland browns had that smacked of not
trying in years one and two
um and you know um there was a contract
extension based on how i
executed that like that's another i
guess similar way of saying what we're
just we're talking about but what about
other coaches joining brian flores to
say that they believe they were part of
sham interviews
and that something needs to be done on
the rooney rule front and thus they're
going to join brian flores in this
action any thoughts on on that right now
that you're here yeah i think you i
think you'll see some names added um
it's tough for active coaches of course
you know and
so how many active coaches are going to
be willing to stick their neck out i'm
not sure
um you know what i can tell you is
quietly you know flo has a lot of
support here
and
i i think the feel that i've gotten just
talking to people over the last three or
four days
is this isn't so much one guy
sticking his neck just sticking his neck
out and narrowing his own grievances
this is the frustration of you know the
lack of progress over the last 19 years
reaching a tipping point and ultimately
boiling over
and you know i think the best way to
kind of describe what's happening here
rich is that they're changing they're
attempting to change the venue um a lot
of people don't know this but they don't
remember it but 19 years ago the rooney
rule went in
because of the threat of litigation and
because johnny cochran had put together
a report that basically detailed all of
the issues the nfl had
trying to become more diverse in its
ranks or not trying to become more
diverse in its ranks that's how the
rooney rule started and the nfl put the
rooney rule in to avoid that litigation
going forward the nfl in essence changed
the venue from the courts to their own
system right
and so now
what these what what brian flores and
other people supporting him are trying
to do or they're saying the nfl system
doesn't work so we're going to change
the venue back from the nfl system to
the courts in order to put pressure on
the owners and put pressure on the
league
to try to create some sort of change and
in that way rich it's not that different
than the concussion lawsuit because
the concussion laws that was sort of
borne out of frustration that the league
wouldn't like but the the league and the
owners
weren't going to concede there was a
problem we're going to do enough to
create change in those guys lives so
they decided they needed to take it to
the courts
to try and
try and get some level of admission of
guilt some level of of of of reparations
for what they've gone through in this
case
i i think it's just about trying to find
some some way to to to to to provoke
change
and you know again i i think that they
feel like the rooney rule this isn't
like
this isn't for any lack of effort by the
league office because league office has
tried
but it's more so just there not being
enough change in the way
this uh the hiring practices have worked
and
you know on the part of the owners and
so their hope is that this will put
pressure on the owners and maybe create
real change because change inside the
nfl system hasn't worked or diversity
amongst ownership about um i mean right
right and and you know i know the denver
broncos are up for sale maybe that could
be uh
you know a start uh right there albert
perry here on the rich eisen show uh all
right let's get to the uh the uh uh i
guess filet mignon here a little bit
what happened with jim harbaugh in
minnesota what happened there
well so here's what i can tell you um
just as um i think was adam that
reported that um that that that harbaugh
had gone to michigan and said you know
i'm coming back
uh the vikings were in the process of
informing the other candidates the other
finalists
that they were out
um and so you know i i think at that
point they they were sort of wrapping up
their process and jim was the last
interview
um and i'm not saying the interview
wasn't on the level
but
they decided pretty quickly after the
interview that they were going with
kevin o'connell
and so you know my feeling was and my
feeling has been
um
that jim i think has always had
unfinished business in the nfl and that
getting that close and coming within a a
goal line stand of winning a super bowl
that's always sort of lingered with him
and sat with him and
um and i i think he's always felt like
i still have something left to
accomplish at that level um last year um
as
uh as michigan
you know was looking at extending him
and ultimately decided to try to get him
to take the pay cut he'd sniffed around
all the jobs and i know the jets and
chargers in particular had had peelers
put out there wasn't a ton of interest
then
so obviously much more successful this
year beats ohio state wins the big ten
goes to the playoff
you know now like maybe my stock is a
little higher so he sniffs around the
raiders and then the vikings job becomes
a possibility when a guy he knows and
plessy adopted mensah
got the the gm job there now all of a
sudden he's in position to get an
interview
um you know and so i think the question
going forward is going to be
does he still need to scratch that itch
because i do think him not winding up in
the nfl
was more about there not being an
opportunity for him this year it wasn't
that he just chose to go back to
michigan and i listen he's gonna say all
the right things and maybe
maybe maybe that's deep down in his
belly maybe that's what's there like now
i'm just going back to michigan and this
can be the rest of my career um all i
know is i've heard for for for years
that there was that that itch that jim
harbaugh felt like he'd he'd eventually
need to scratch in the nfl
and so i think at least that bad signal
is out there now where if an nfl team's
interested in jim harbaugh there'd be no
reason not to at least make that phone
call down the line well i guess the
proof will be in the the buyout number
right what do you think yeah i mean yeah
are you hearing if there's a new
contract coming for him yeah i'd heard
there was an offer on the table um for
him and that that had been sitting there
for a while and listen like
i
one of the things i one of the things i
find one thing that i really like about
jim that i think is is great about him
um i really respect the grudge held rich
and uh that dude knows how to hold a
grudge
good one
i very much respect that about him and i
and i do think like having to take the
pay cut like that was that was hard for
him like that was humiliating you know
and i and i and i do think that to some
degree like and i'm not saying he's mad
at the school in general he's obviously
not loves his players he's not mad at
his players or
the people in the program but but i do
think that like he held a grudge with
the people the individual people who
made him take that pay cut a year ago
and i do think that that was a part of
this was making them squirm and making
them a little uncomfortable over the
last month now is the reason he did it
no i think he had a legitimate interest
in going the nfl
but if you know doing this on national
signing day
made
certain people uncomfortable then i do
think that that was at least a little
bit of a benefit to him and uh
i mean like it's just it's it's a
perfect it's it's a great part of his
personality you know like because it's
just kind of like what you'd expect in a
situation like this and um
so so yeah i mean i i think it's i think
that was definitely a part of it and now
coming out of it
um it'll be interesting to see if he
just signs what was sitting there on his
desk
um over the last month or so
if the school seeks an adjustment if he
seeks a little bit more
it'll be interesting to see how that
plays out over the next couple of weeks
well i mean uh michigan's best season
under harbaugh on best season in such a
long time to be followed up with a month
of intrigue and and uh potential discord
congratulations on that albert uh to you
and well i guess you
know
while congratulations are also in order
congratulations on joe burrow saying to
everybody he's still a buckeye and he
considers himself still a buck i know
that's very important i will i i will
congratulations for resisting the urge
to send that to you either on social no
it's all right i saw it i saw it
i said i followed both you and james
palmer and i see how they were you were
congratulating each other and talking
about oh we have the same degree as him
don't we because he agrees on all that
so i i wanted to issue congratulations
to you that joe burrow reminding
everybody that he's still a buckeye and
he considers himself still a buck i know
that's very important to you and so i do
look forward to the um the opening of
the super bowl because nbc has everybody
introduced themselves and what school
they're from i can't wait for him to say
joe boro
the ohio state that's what he'll say
right that's what he'll say well maybe
he won't but sam sam hubbard will and
von bell will of course no you can go
right on down the list if you want
absolutely
there are a lot of there are a lot of
joe burrows former teammates on that on
that um on that true bengals roster and
by the way one of the one of the rams
captains yeah i don't know if you're
familiar with jordan fuller yes and he
won't be playing in the game because
he's hurt but he would be able to be
one of the captains of uh the rams
absolutely
absolutely and and i just hope that joe
doesn't say joe burrow lsu but also the
ohio state where i have a degree because
then
for you no no no no no it would hurt for
the production like they would by the
time that everybody introduces
themselves we'd have to you know it
would it would talk over the snap like
you know it would be bad it would take
too much time it'd be too much time but
congratulations you know what you know
what joe burrow does have what do you
know he does have what does he have he
has three pairs of gold pants because he
was 3-0 against michigan was he i don't
remember him playing against michigan he
was three you know well everything i
don't remember him playing i don't
remember him
playing yeah
are you going to ask him if you have him
on ever ask him how many pairs of coins
i remember him leaving i remember
remember him playing at ohio state but i
guess he did you actually don't even
remember him leaving because nobody knew
who he was
we sure do now we sure do know all right
albert thanks for the time appreciate it
all right thank you so much have a great
weekend you bet same to you that's
albert everybody
always have a little fun with albert
or him having fun with me at my expense
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here